-Welcome, everybody.
Welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show"!
[ Cheers and applause ]
This is exciting.
Michelle Obama
is on the show tonight!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yep, she'll be talking about
eating healthy
while I work through
last night's
double corned-beef sandwich
on rye.
Let's get to the news.
Well, guys, the drama between
President Biden and
Vladimir Putin continues.
A day after Biden called
Putin a killer,
Putin responded by saying,
"It takes one to know one."
-Sheesh!
-This is fun.
As if the pandemic
wasn't enough,
let's throw in tension with
a "nuclear enemy" into the mix.
Why not?
Don't worry.
Biden isn't scared by this.
Just to be safe, he skipped
wearing underwear today
just in case they were poisoned.
Yep, these guys
are really going at it.
But keep in mind,
it could also be just
a marketing stunt for
Sunglass Hut.
Just saying.
Just think about it.
The Kremlin also weighed in
and called Biden's comments
about Putin "very bad"
and demanded
an explanation or an apology.
Then Biden was like,
"Well, which one do you want?
Explanation or apology?"
Yep, the Kremlin demanded that
Biden explain himself,
which will backfire
when they realize
every Biden explanation
takes at least three hours.
"I know a Russian guy
named Igor.
We used to call him Scooter
'cause he had a bicycle
with no pedals.
He would scoot
his way to school."
Wow! But things didn't
stop there,
because later today,
Putin invited Biden to have
a public live-streamed chat
either tomorrow or Monday.
Somehow, we went from, "It takes
a killer to know a killer" to
"You free for
Zoom happy hour later?
Just saying, it could be fun.
Just a couple palsies."
Yep, it's a busy time for Biden.
Today, his
administration announced
that they are sending millions
of AstraZeneca vaccine doses
to Canada and Mexico.
That's nice.
We're giving them
the one vaccine
that isn't approved in the U.S.
It's like telling a houseguest,
"Hey, if you're hungry,
there's a frozen Lean Cuisine
from 1989 in the garage.
Don't touch our food.
Go at it.
Go at it with that lasagna."
Here's some more big news
out of our nation's capital.
As of this week, magic mushrooms
are now decriminalized
in Washington, D.C.
-What?!
[ Laughter ]
-You can already see a
difference with some lawmakers.
Take a look at how
they were behaving
before and after
the 'shrooms kicked in.
Watch this.
-Let's pass this bill!
The brain is an amazing organ.
-How critical it is that we do
something about COVID.
Go smoke some dope and you will
enjoy life so much more.
-Fear has become an
all-too-prevalent quality.
This is, of course, a picture of
former president Ronald Reagan.
And actually firing
a machine gun
while riding on the back
of a dinosaur.
-Wait. That's real?
What?!
-Some sports news.
Well, everyone is
pumped for this.
It is March Madness!
That's right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Everyone is doing
their office pools.
Of course, this year, that means
it's you against your wife,
your 2-year-old, and your dog.
"Rusty, you picked
Gonzaga, too?"
And this is cool -- fans will be
allowed in the arenas,
but capacity will be limited.
So to add some extra excitement,
CBS is making the
sneaker squeaks 50% louder.
[ Sneakers squeaking ]
"And there's pass from Jennings.
Oh, he's got the easy lay-up.
Jennings has got
the easy lay-up!
Oh, rejected out of the..."
[ Squeaking stops ]
-Wait.
[ Sneakers squeaking ]
"There is a pass over to
Okanuba.
Okanuba passes
back to Jennings!
He's down in the paint
and he's..."
[ Squeaking stops ]
[ Sneakers squeaking ]
No, don't play it -- I can't.
I'm out of breath.
-Please, please.
-Well, this is great, though.
Do you guys remember
Sister Jean?
She was the nun who was
the biggest fan of
Loyola Chicago
basketball team?
-Oh, yeah.
-Yeah.
Well, her school is back
in the tournament,
and at 101 years old, she's been
cleared to attend the game.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah.
I love Sister Jean.
She's Loyola's most beloved fan
and their most
unforgiving bookie.
You thought a ruler was bad.
She walks around with a pipe.
"Contributions
a little light this week."
When asked how it felt to be
allowed to attend,
Sister Jean said
she was "#Blessed."
[ Laughter ]
Sister Jean, yeah.
The team loves Sister Jean.
Before tip-off, she always has
the same uplifting message --
"Have fun out there and don't be
afraid to stuff a fool,
you freshman bitch."
What?
That's just...
And, finally,
this is pretty wild.
A man in New York was
just convicted
of a very unusual crime.
Watch this.
-A man in New York was convicted
of illegal trafficking
after keeping live sharks
in a pool at his home
and offering them for sale
on the Internet.
-Even the sharks were like,
"Ugh, an aboveground pool?"
Right now, Vladimir Putin is
trying to set up the meeting
with Biden directly
over that tank.
[ Russian accent ]
Just take two more steps closer.
The Wi-Fi is better there."
[ Buzzer ]
Alright.